does this politicization of the issue
help trans people no 100
i'm gonna tell you no
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people we've got all kinds
of fascinating guests for you today he's
an adult film producer
performer and our first uh transsexual
man on the show black angel welcome to
trigonometry
right on thank you for having me i'm the
first wow
first transsexual man we've had lots of
trans women on the show but
not so much on the other way and i think
that would be one of the things
that would be interesting to talk to you
about before we do though
just tell everybody your story who are
you how are you where you are
what is the journey that brings you here
to be talking to us because your story
is really really interesting
well thank you first off thanks really
for uh having me on i appreciate giving
me the space
so i'm a transsexual man which means i
was uh
born female so and transitioned to live
as a man
uh 26 years ago so biologically i'm
female
i never felt that way whatever that
means it's a difficult space to
kind of tell people because it's like i
don't feel like a woman i felt like a
man so i had a change to fit my space
and
i walked the world as a man i got into
pornography i created the genre of trans
male pornography 21 years ago
from there my voice just got into the
universe and i became a public speaker
and i travel the world now talking about
my transition
26 years ago which was a whole other
level of transition than it is today and
i also identify as a transsexual man so
hopefully we can have that discussion
along the way well let's let's talk
about that first of all because
i i don't even know what what's the
difference between a trans person and a
transsexual person
sure so so what what for me this is how
i actually explain it now people are
going to argue with it whatever but this
is my
identity and my story so yeah it's the
internet people are going to argue
whatever you say right they're going to
tell me my story is wrong
that's the best part about it so so that
being said
for a transsexual person is a
medicalized space so it's
so for example i'm gonna use myself i
never felt like a woman i always felt
like a dude
i wanted to transition to live in the
biola in the in the space of
binary male so i wanted to go from
living as a woman to living as a man i
use medical intervention i have my
breasts removed i
take testosterone for the rest of my
life and i masculinize myself as you see
i look like a man and people think i'm a
man so that's really where
transsexual people live we live in a
space where we want to go from one
binary to the other and we don't want
people to know our background we just
want to live as men and women
transgender is now an umbrella term that
encompasses
every variation of gen of gender so it
can be somebody who's non-binary even
somebody like myself if they choose to
be in the transgender space
so the difference for me is that
transsexual is more of a medicalized
space where somebody wants to live in
the binary
and a transgender is an identity space
so these people are choosing the
identity of transgender i'm not i'm not
mine is not an identity choice mine is a
medical space
if that makes sense so it's a really
lovely explanation buck thank you
why do you think it is that it's more
contentious
it seems to me anyway for male to female
transition than for female to male
yeah that's a great question and so
again you know not being a trans woman i
don't have the same experience as them
but as a trans man and looking at the
whole space
it's just much harder for men
to transition to women it could be a
physical thing right there's some things
for a person like myself who
transitioned from a woman to a man
it was just about taking testosterone
growing a beard right going to the gym
and putting on muscles and wearing a
a sweatshirt i look like a dude i think
on some levels sometimes it's harder to
transition from male to female
physically because especially if you're
doing it later in life you have male
characteristics that you have people in
the world see visually
right so there's a visual space that we
as trans people live in
and that space can be difficult if
you're not what we use as the word
passing
and so i think the reason you see more
male to females voices out there is i
think that they come from a socialized
male space
and men are different than women when it
comes to everything in the world
so men are taught to be more boisterous
men are taught to put themselves in
spaces where women are taught to be much
more meek
and so i come from a socialized female
space
where we're not supposed to be putting
our voice in there we're not so i
for me when i'm looking at everything
and i see such a wider
space of of mail to females in the voice
space
i think it's really socialization and
they come from a space where they have
been taught to be
boisterous if that makes sense is there
not also another part of this book which
is
you are no danger to men in their
experience
right if i saw you in in a bathroom
i i'd be like well it's another dude in
the bathroom we're both having appears
great
right but for women the experience of
someone who's a lot bigger a lot
stronger and all of that
that they experience that as a threat
and you know we have a lot of female
fans whose
major concern around all of this stuff
is the safety of women the safety of
girls
you know women's sports all of that sort
of stuff that's a big part of it as well
isn't it
oh sure it's a huge big part and no one
wants to have the conversation
on both sides right we have to ease into
this this isn't an easy space to go into
now
i'm not part of that conversation as a
trans person i'm part of that
conversation as somebody who lived as a
female
for half of my life i was in sports i
was everything i was a very butch woman
i lived as a butch woman and i lived in
that space of female
and it is a hundred percent true that
women are still
on the bottom of the of the barrel it's
a real thing
and so that being said i think that
there's no discussion between trans
women
and biological women where how can we
start to have the conversation
where we can move into spaces together
we need to hear both sides you can't
just hear
trans people we have to hear women as
and biological women as well we need to
say well why are biological women
acting this way and saying they're so
scared of trans women and why are trans
women saying
well that's transphobic and you're a
turf if you do that no one's
no one's coming to a space where we're
like listening to each other
and listening to fears because
everyone's fears are valid
everyone's but we need to understand why
are they and why are
why is this side having a fear why is
this side having a fear because
there's valid reasons why they are i
hear your approach and it sounds great
it does sound great but i'll tell you
what the problem that i think
we have here is it's not just about
people
not willing to listen it's also about
the fact that particularly when you talk
about something like sport but also
you know female prisons right there are
some things that just
irreconcilable differences where that's
right where
you know let's say safety has to take
priority
over you know feelings of comfort
and being accepted and whatever do you
think i mean there are some areas like
that surely aren't there
a hundred percent there is and there's a
hundred percent of people
using trans as a way to get into another
prison there's no doubt about
that i and anyone who denies that
especially in the trans community
is not helping the trans community
because there are people who are
latching on that possibly are not trans
who are possibly are using it to use the
system
now i don't know i can't tell you the
percentage of people that are doing that
but a hundred percent and also yeah
there are people that
that we just need to have some kind of
conversation about this because people
are freaking out
and people are saying wait a minute here
there are people who are not trans but
pretending to be trans or saying and
here's the deal if you can just self id
as a woman
what like that's like insane so
any of you two guys sitting there could
self id as a woman right now
say i'm a woman not make any attempt to
look like a woman
i could be a butch woman though you're
totally good
[Laughter]
you opened that door dude
to be honest with you bucky that door
has been open for him by thousands and
thousands of youtube comments over the
years
yeah i love it but i take your point
it's a good point anyone can just
if anyone can self id that opens the
door to some
a very small minority but some people
who want to use it for sinister purposes
right
that's right and i'm going to say it
right here and everyone can be mad at me
but that's like the real
here's you know i'm so frustrated you
guys i'm so frustrated because i have
opinions or i want to talk about things
and they might not sound like so great
or perfect or whatever people need me to
say
i'm saying things because i want to have
conversation about it
you guys are bringing it up with me
because now we can start to bridge a gap
we need to bridge a gap there the gap of
conversation it could
conversation hurts people's feelings and
people don't want to have their feelings
hurt anymore which is a very weird
place to be right i mean we need to we
need to get down to
understanding why people don't like
trans people or why people are pushing
back on us or why people
think certain things about us and if we
have conversation hopefully people will
start to see
there there is nuanced in this
conversation that's not being heard
and buck aren't you ever surprised with
just how toxic
this debate is i remember when i first
got into the
when we first got into doing the show
people said this is the most toxic
debate you can be involved it and i was
shocked i'm shocked too and it's
absolutely depressing for me to be
you know 26 years i transition 20 plus
years i've been in
really advocating for trans stuff and
you know i put myself out there
all over the world naked i've been i've
been everywhere and doing everything to
sort of like
just bridge this gap or at least just be
accepted you know i have been accepted
in the world people like me there's
you know even though i did pornography
or i do pornography people still
like me because i'm willing to have
conversation and so i don't understand
how we've gotten to this and it's not
just about trans issues you guys know
that
i don't understand everyone's triggered
everyone's upset
no one can have a conversation we're
gonna cancel you who where do we live
in what world are we building we're
building a very scary world
we are building a very very scary world
does this politicization
of the issue help trans people no
100 i'm gonna tell you no because now
look
where are we we're having me and you are
having these conversations
when i can tell you two or three years
ago i was having conversations with guys
like you about my work in porn
about how you know great just different
converse how cool it was that i
transitioned
everyone would always be like that it's
so cool how you transition
now it's like people are becoming
anti-transitioning because they're
seeing things in my community
that i don't even like there are things
in the community i don't even like and
i'm pushing back on my community because
i can't imagine what the rest of the
world sees
and if i'm pushing back on my on parts
of my community what the rest of the
world sees might be
insane and you say parts of
you pushing back on things in your
community that you don't like what are
these things buck
well the most important thing for me are
the kids and
it is this makes me emotional i'll be
honest with you
it does because i was one of those kids
i was a trans kid right but we didn't
call it that back in the day but that
being said i know where these kids are
hurting i understand what's going on
but the thing that i do not understand
in my community is
medicalizing children i do not believe
in it i do not think it is smart
i do not think it will aleve until i see
lots of studies on that
why are we messing with kids medically
you know kids grow out of stuff
i'm not saying they're all going to grow
out of it but i'm going to tell you once
you medicalize a child that child is
medicalized for the rest of their life
and and why would we do that just to
make them trans or to
alleviate things we don't even know we
have no cert research on how this is
going to help the future of children we
do not
and we're lying when we say we do
because i look for it
nobody can give it to me it's not there
we have we have research on
on the blockers and how they can be
destructive
on long term physically well but
this is uh such an important issue
though you bring up and i'm glad you're
the one that brought it up because
you know my intuitive sense of i i was
born in in the soviet union and later
lived in russia
and now living in the west i have an
intuitive sense of just how decent
and welcoming and open-minded people in
the west are in general and
i think that also will apply to the
trans issue
too but when you start talking we
covered a story on the show a few days
ago about
a two-year-old whose parents were on
television
and they were being praised and
celebrated as for encouraging and
supporting their trans
two-year-old the two-year-old they don't
even have a concept of gender right
but when the general public in in
britain here and in america where you
are see that
i think that's what's pushing a lot of
people into the sort of like
there's something wrong here whereas in
the past they were just going oh buck
you're transitioning great you know
you're an adult you do you
that's right that's right no you hit it
right on the head my friend and that's
why i
talk about it look i don't want any kid
to suffer and shame on anyone who thinks
that about me
that's not why i've done the work i've
done or put myself out there in the
world naked i did not do that i've been
beat up for 20 something years my
friends and i have grown a thick skin
because of it
but that being said because my ultimate
goal was to teach the world that
it's not what you think it is and the
man walking down the street might not be
the man you think he
is and so what by opening myself up like
that i'm really doing a lot of work to
sort of expose
us now i feel like we're going backwards
when you bring
kids when you bring kids into an
equation
and medicalizing kids at such a fast
rate
with not giving the rest of the world
time to catch up of course everyone's
going to say wait a minute here
and we should be kids are the future and
when you start to mess with kids
medically mess with kids how are those
kids going to be as adults do we even
know
are they actually going to be okay what
what's this thing called d
transitioners where are d transitioners
coming from do you know that
i've never in the in the 26 years of my
transition i never saw d transitioners
before all of a sudden the last five
even the last two years they're popping
out like
mad they have organizations they have
that says to me something's wrong with
the system
and what do you think it is because we
obviously in the uk you'll be
i'm sure familiar with the case of kiera
bell of course yes we've had marcus
evans from the tavistock clinic which
uh he was a bit of a whistleblower there
and his wife as well
and and essentially what we're talking
what you're hinting at i think
is am i correct to say that you think
people have been encouraged
to transition who were maybe not
supposed to of course i'm saying that
100
because we're teaching look i'm not
scared to say anything i just want you
guys to know
i am scared that's why i want you to say
it because
you should be you'll get nailed too i
i get nailed too but what are they gonna
do i'm a trans
i'm a transsexual person who's been in
this community for 26 years
you go ahead and try to cancel me i'll
get more pissed
and i'll make sure that i'm on more
[ __ ] news stations and more spaces
like this and get my voice more powerful
don't come after me people have a
conversation with me
i do not play and i will not play when
it comes to children
i am disgusted that our community is
pushing this forward
as if it's just something that we should
all just lay down and be
i want to question it and if i want to
question it you guys should question it
and that makes me say
you care okay you care about my
community i'm going to cry because
again how are we talking about children
how are we even having this discussion
and everyone's acting as if well buck
that's not
that's not right these kids will kill
themselves do you know that you're
giving them that language
when you give kids the language i'm
gonna kill myself what do they do oh
i'm gonna kill myself if i don't
transition they never had that language
before
when we start to put this stuff out
there it's taking away
from the reality of what this did for me
which is to save my life
and it's not a joke and it's not
something we should just be forcing on
everybody we should find out what's
going on with this person
figure out if they are trans that's
great if they're not that's great too
and then we can move forward but we're
not doing that i feel like we're just
pushing
and when children come into the equation
i'm not shutting up i refuse
and i don't care because i see the
future of those kids in a way that i
want them to be like me
i don't want them to be screwed up tyra
bell got screwed up
for a reason and because nobody's having
the conversation
and it's true we're not having the
conversation do you think part of the
problem as well buck is that
when people think of transition they
tend to think oh it's a little click of
the fingers that's right and then you've
transitioned but what they don't realize
is like you've been talking about you're
going to take testosterone for the rest
of your life
that's right i am medicalized for the
rest of my i hate
you guys you think i like being a trans
dude i hate it
but i [ __ ] figured it out i figured
it out i walk the world i
am a happy person don't get me wrong i'm
so happy i have the most beautiful
amazing life i can't
even imagine i'm still here but that
being said why would i want somebody to
be like this
when maybe they're not like this and
maybe they can just find space that that
they just can figure it out and not have
to be medicalized
i mean to medicalize a a an
eight-year-old
a seven-year-old we're starting at that
age why why i don't understand to me
that says wait a minute here where
that's an agenda because why wouldn't
you want to just have a little mental
health care for a couple years
you know i was socially transitioned if
you you know when you social transition
it means you dress differently you get
to dress like a boy
my parents dressed me like a boy let me
be a boy i was socially transitioned
that that was an amazing space for me to
be in and
and so yeah i suffered during a second
part of my life but i did not suffer as
a child because my parents just let me
be buck
i'm totally all about social
transitioning then what if the kid
decides they're not trans right then
it's just like okay we'll just change it
back to a dress
we don't have to fix like everything we
just screwed up with medication
well that's an interesting part of your
story because we we kind of got into the
political side of this very quickly but
yeah
your parents your parents and you would
do because it's so politicized now but
actually as you say
there are more interesting conversations
to be had i think and i think your case
is particularly interesting because
for particularly you know you're in your
50s now uh
you grew up at a time where acceptance
of this type of thing was even less than
it is now
but your parents were quite supportive
right you you were not
growing up with sort of parents who were
punishing you or being
and and still your life was quite hard
and you had some family term all over it
and
alcohol and other sort of problems right
yep all of it i was drug addict
addiction all
cutter i was a cutter i was all of those
things remember i grew up in the 60s and
70s
that's a whole other i i even
transitioned in the time of no social
media
which i say thank god thank the universe
for that seriously because i think
that's a lot of the problems that are
happening in my community is social
media
and this attachment that now they they
can connect with each other worldwide
and start to
create some kind of rhetoric or some
space where they're i think they're
pulling people into this idea that
and the kids can't think straight
because they're all being told
how to think and they're all and i was
never told that i always got to find my
own path on my own terms
it must be really difficult buck because
we've spoken to douglas murray about
this
where you know people becoming being gay
is no longer a sexuality it's almost a
political identity same with trans
that's right that must be very very
difficult walking to room and everyone
goes oh they're trans
i therefore know everything about the
way they think that's right
it's weird it's weird that's what i told
you why there's a difference between a
transsexual person and a transgender
person
trans sexual people never wanted to be
anything other than a man or woman
you know we just wanted to grow look
this way go back into the world and we
want to be a part of the world it's what
i keep to
i want to be a part of the world i want
to hang out with you guys i want to be
i don't want to be this trans guy that
i'm just part i want to be a man a part
of the world
and that's where i actually built my
space everyone looks at me as a man they
don't
now this trance thing is so huge they're
attaching that to me
and it's like that was never my
intention was to be a trans man my
intention was to be men so you see
the political sizing of it it has made
it into a space that is now something
different than where i come from it is
now an identity choice
it's a whole other space and i don't i
don't understand how we've been
put into this space now and now how big
our voices in the politics side it
i you know what that's not what trans is
about it's about finding your space and
living life and
and and moving forward because that's
what transition means it's from one to
the other it's not
you're not stuck in this space so i you
know it makes me sad that we're here
because people
never have acted this way towards us
hey constantine how are you feeling good
and your mental health i'm from russia
we don't have mental health
well in the civilized world we talk
about our mental health
and how we're feeling about our place in
the universe
in the words of my uncle vlad that is
why we will crush you
well he's two months away from a
breakdown for the rest of us
there's a number one mental wellness app
called calm
that helps you to negotiate the tricky
modern world
it's okay to need help sometimes and
calm can provide support
calm has been really useful for me you
can clear your head with
guided daily meditations improve your
focus with calms curated music tracks
and drift off to dreamland with calm's
imaginative sleep stories
narrated by soothing voices like killian
murphy
and stephen fry oh killian save me
man up drink vodka feel better if you go
to calm.com
trigger you'll get a limited time offer
of 40 percent off
a calm premium subscription which
includes hundreds of hours of
programming
and new content is added every week over
1 million people
around the world use calm to take care
of their minds
yes trigonometry fans get special
limited time promotion 40
off premium subscription take advantage
of this amazing offer go to com.com
forward slash trigger
for 40 percent of unlimited access to
calm entire library that's calm dot com
forward slash trigger
that that's really interesting and uh
and i by the way i
i accept your you didn't say it this way
but it is a kind of criticism that's
quite legitimate where
we're having you on and i introduce you
as the first transsexual man we've had
on the show
we're really you're a human being that
we could talk to other
about other stuff that might be more
interesting so i kind of accept your
criticism but
at the same time we're sort of in this
paradigm now where this
does have to be ventilated and people
like you have to be heard to be speaking
you by your experience so it's it's a
kind of it's a conundrum
for all of us i think to work out no and
i want you to know that that's why i'm
here
i'm here because of that but before i
used to go on
shows because you know i because i was a
transsexual man but other you know other
things and they're talking about my
stuff and my
but you understand what i'm saying now
it just functions like oh my god it's
like the number one topic on every news
day
i i i don't think it's doing us any good
i do not think it's doing us anything
but let me ask you this because you've
hinted at her already
i take it you're not a fan of the whole
non-binary phenomenon
well no i'm okay so yeah that's a great
question because i get nailed all the
time in the community you're
anti-non-binary
here's what happened and you know here's
the other thing if you say something
wrong
20 years ago they pull it out they go
digging through the internet and find
something i said 20. i'm like
i'm like that's 20 years ago find
something relevant like maybe in the
last year
that i said that so so anyway that being
said yeah um
uh what was i'm sorry what was i said
about non-binary what non-binary because
that's like a huge thing i got
so i am not anti-non-binary what i said
was
non-binary people are not trans but that
was before
trans became an umbrella term now it's
an umbrella term so trans encompasses
anything and anybody that has a
variation of gender so non-binary to me
is that
identity choice remember what i said
earlier mine is not an identity choice
my so for me non-binary exists if that's
what you want to be and you're in some
kind of space you go right ahead
but for me it doesn't equate to where
i'm at so i don't want to be put in the
same space as non-binary does that make
sense
i don't live under the same umbrella as
non-binary that is not my
kind of trans that is getting a little
bit
confusing here so let me ask you this in
a more simple way
how many genders are there
great question dude [ __ ] if i know
i don't know and this day and age
there's like five million as far as
but you know the reality of it sex let's
talk about biological sex
i believe in biological sex it's the
reason i'm transsexual i was born i was
not assigned i was born a female
110 the doctor saw it
the doctor did it that you know so i was
born a female dude
and the other thing is i don't like
people putting words in my mouth for my
story i was not assigned a female i was
born a female
i wasn't comfortable with it and i
transitioned to live bell but i will
always be a biological female forever
forever and ever and ever
you cannot change biology that this is
because i look like a man does not make
me biologically a man
and why is it that that is such a
contentious thing to say
you know like you've heard people
getting in trouble people getting
fired from job etc etc etc
because i don't know it's funny this is
such good comedy stuff for you guys but
you'll get nailed
yeah yeah if i want to get shot yeah and
that bums me out you know what i
love comedy i make fun of my clearly i'm
like i like the man with the vagina
right i'm like
it's funny it's hilarious like i love to
laugh at myself i love to laugh at my
transition i know it's not
funny funny but it's my transition and
here's the deal like if we don't make
fun of ourselves on some level then
we've become so
gross and it's just so hard and no one
no one can have conversation with us so
it's just like i don't you know taking
ourselves too seriously on some level
is not the way to live life you can't
live life that way
but it seems that we are and that we do
i
i guess one of the questions i really
wanted to ask buck
is do you think now we've gone too far
with this identity this obsession with
identity
and if we have what is a way to come
back from it
here's what i don't understand is why
are we having such this
um you know staunch
idea of what gender is and why are we
having this idea that biology doesn't
exist and why are we trying
we not me i'm not part of that but why
is there a faction okay it's not
all the trend i need also everybody out
there to understand this is not the
whole trans community
there are a lot of trans people who do
not like what's going on either so i
need for you to
know that there are a lot of people like
me who are not happy but that being said
i feel as if they're trying to overrun
like
like the world and like telling and re
redefining
for the whole world what it means to be
a man and a woman and i don't understand
why they would even that's
so arrogant that is so arrogant and
narcissistic i can't even believe that
you think you know
better than what the rest of the rest
99.9
of the world is binary and by and
believes in biology
do you know the trans community is like
zero zero zero point
three percent of the population or
something and here we are with such
power
to actually override other people
forcing people to use
pronouns forcing people to say that you
know
if you don't do this you're transphobic
how is
i'm telling i'm actually asking this
question out loud too because i don't
understand
where the power is coming from and why
we think that we
are so much more superior than you
but this is an issue we've explored a
lot on this show
and you'll be as familiar with it as we
are but do you not think that a large
part of this
over the problems that you're talking
about is simply a product of the fact
that
we now live in a society where the more
of a victim you are
the more power you have and so and and
and the trans community is right at the
top of that list
and therefore you've got power if you
want you don't use it but if you wanted
to you could be like
oh constantin said the sing in the
course of our interview
cancel him that's right and people would
do it
they would in a heartbeat i mean they'll
try to cancel me on a daily basis and
people
get on board with it for a while and
then they stop doing it it's just
ridiculous but that being said
yeah you're right that's why any that's
why these conversations are so difficult
that because nobody will talk about it
i'm i'm willing to talk about it because
i don't think that every
anything will get taken care of if we
don't have the conversation
i i like to say i like to build bridges
i like to be that guy between you and my
and that community over there i don't
even like to call it my community
anymore
because it's such a mess and there's so
many factions of it that i don't agree
with
and i don't want to be connected to that
i want to be connected to creating a
better world that's the reason i'm here
i want to create a better world for all
of us
not everyone's going to like trans
people that's just a reality i've lived
within my whole life i lived with it as
a gay woman
i've been beat up somehow now you can't
be beat up or that's like you know what
i mean
by beat up i mean you can't have any
opposing views
so this idea that we're so sensitive
around trans people is ridiculous
and i don't understand honestly i can't
even answer any of your questions
because i don't
as a 58 year old trans guy i don't
understand it
let me put the counter argument to you i
mean you mentioned you know forcing
people to use pronouns
yeah look you've chosen to to identify
as a man
right and when talking about you i would
say buck angel he
right but some people might say well you
forced me to do that
but if i said block angel she that would
be disrespectful and rude
well yeah but here's what's happened i'm
mature and so what happens with maturity
is
you laugh it off and you're like that
dude is just doing that to be that way
because look at me
i mean it's clear that i'm a man now but
if you want to be a jerk you're going to
say she
here's what that's what i know and i'm
trying to teach the kids that
i'm trying to i don't care if you put
she he there or whatever you're putting
there
people are gonna see what they see and
sometimes people are gonna mess up your
pronouns
your people do still say she to me
they're like you're a biological woman
you're still a she
whatever dude i don't care i'm not
living my life for you
we're teaching we are teaching bad
behavior when we teach people to get
so upset because somebody mispro you
know
mispronounce you or whatever the hell is
going on that's not the real world
forever you will be misgendered forever
i get misgendered now and i look like
this so
i don't like the way we're teaching this
sensitivity level that's so
sensitive like it's just insanely
sensitive that we
that's not going to do any of us any
good you guys are angry and we're angry
and now we're fighting each other
um buck do you think part of the problem
is because i think society was has been
made aware
and is aware that the issue of gay
rights was handled disgracefully
for a long period of time you know the
gay gay people the gay community
suffered a lot and it's honestly until
recently that they were able to get
married etc etc
and people are looking at trans and
thinking [ __ ] we don't want to make the
same mistake again
and we'll let's go all the way with this
do you think that's part of the problem
you know here's steel i've been fighting
for gay rights for 30 plus years it's my
community where i have been and so i've
seen a lot i lost a lot of friends
during the aids crisis like it was
insane what i've seen and what i've gone
through with this community it's
resilient beyond belief
and so we still don't have the gay
rights you're talking about yeah we can
get married any other thing but
people are still majorly homophobic you
know that as well as i do
that's not something that will ever
change i do not believe it
so i use that same analogy when it comes
to the trans community
people are not are forever going to
accept us and trans it's just going to
be this normalized thing it's not
it's also not a normalized thing this is
an actual condition i have
it's called gender dysphoria it's not
just some so that's why i'm telling you
there's a difference here between
where where i'm at it's a medical
condition that a medic
i would have killed myself if this
didn't happen and i'm not saying that
my story is the end all be all but now
we have identity choices where kids are
saying they don't even have dysphoria
and they're trans so i'm like what
why would you ever want to be trans you
know it's like saying i'm gay but i'm
not gay
because i want to be gay like what
so yeah i was just gonna say but because
you you've alluded to you know why would
you want to be trans i think this is
really important
what it what is the life of a trans
person like
particularly when it comes to the
medication the day-to-day because i
think it's really important that people
listen to us
from the from the mouth of a trans
person and they actually
understand it for themselves that's
right it's like i work with a lot of
parents here in los angeles and they're
kids
and one of the things i try to really
help them about is let your kid be your
kid
if your kid wants to wear a dress let
them who cares let them wear pants let
them do
that it's like we're not uh it's just i
don't know
i'm frustrated as you can see i really
am because
i don't understand why you would push a
child
into a space that can actually make them
be in this space for the rest of their
lives it is not fun
this hashtag trans is beautiful it's
it's not
a beautiful space to be in it's a space
that you get to
and hopefully that it gets to put you in
a space like me where i'm
a very functioning person and i get to
be this have this great space but i'll
say it again
i wish i wasn't born this way and i wish
i was born as a man
so that being said why would anyone want
to be trans i don't understand that and
so when i
say that i say that's why it's turned
into an identity
choice and so these kids don't have to
have dysphoria and these kids
don't have to take medication but they
can just be called trans
that's the crack in the system right
there that ruined the whole community
because i remember when it happened all
these kids started claiming trans and
they're like we don't have dysphoria and
we don't need to have dysphoria
and then i was like what's happening
here where all these kids becoming trans
without any dysphoria
said something to me that oh wow this
has become an identity this has become
this place where kids just want to be
trans
and so i can't answer the ques i don't
know why it got to that space
and i find it to be quite dangerous to
be honest with you um
it sounds like you're kind of your
thinking is very much where we're at
because
you know the place we started from was
people said to us oh you need to discuss
the transition we're like why
it's an issue that affects a tiny
minority of people it makes no
difference to the vast majority of
people's lives
but then i think and tell me what you
think about this bug because
this is how i've been thinking about it
you know most
normal liberal-minded people are like
look
you're an adult do whatever you want get
on with your life right
but when you start asking me
to believe things that are patently
untrue
that's where i'm like well i'll call you
she
or he or whatever but i'm not gonna
pretend that a biological man
who who has some reassignment or maybe
doesn't
is the same as a woman as a as a female
i'm not gonna pretend that they should
be fighting in a cage together
or or competing in sports or doing any
of those like
or should be in the same prison so i
want to be
welcoming i want to be understanding i
want to be compassionate but on the
other hand i'm confronted
with let's just be honest lies i'm being
confronted with lies
and i i don't want to end up in the big
at camp
but you're but these people are pushing
me in there by forcing me to accept all
these
lies which i'm not going to do and i
that makes me upset
for you as as a transsexual man i don't
want you to be put in that space and i
as a transsexual man would never put you
in that space i just wouldn't
because as you see what did i say
earlier i'm a biological woman
when i when i say that and i put it into
the universe what do you say
well buck's totally living a reality and
i will respect buck
and buck is a he i can't imagine that
you guys would ever call me she
probably would never do that because you
would it would be coming from a
disrespectful space
because i don't disrespect you and you
don't disrespect me
i said to you the reality of my
transition who i am what i'm doing
you're like [ __ ] that's cool dude right
on your
that's that's our connection and you see
that that's the way the world reacts to
me
because i'm living in a reality now
we're putting on the table biology isn't
real
anyone can have a sex chain you don't
have to have dysphoria we're putting all
this nonsense out there that is making
you go
wait a minute here the trans space is
not real
and you're fighting you're pushing
against everything me and many of the
trans elders before me fought for
which is to find our space and have the
world just say hey man if that's the
thing that's going to make you a better
look let me give you an example of my
father the most macho ex
football player imagine you know america
like he's like he's just that dude right
uh you're my daughter you'll always be
my daughter there's no way you're always
gonna be a laura jane
he would call me laura looking like this
i'm like dad people are gonna think
you're nuts
or like out of a restaurant but anyway
finally he just said to me the other day
he's like look
i respect where you're at and i was like
what he goes i get it all this trans
stuff on the tv that i'm seeing now i
get
where you're at and i don't understand
what they're doing to these children
my dad said that he said if that would
have been the opportunity for me to do
that
to you when you were a child because i
wouldn't have done it he said he would
not have done it and he doesn't believe
in that but he now respects me
as a man because he sees what i have
done to create that space and he knows
that
i respect myself and he respects me back
so i don't think we're giving respect to
the world when we're pushing
and we're saying you got to change all
of your beliefs for us
and if you don't change all your beliefs
for us you're a turf you're transphobic
that's not change my friends
that's an ideology that's pushing people
into belief system that they will not i
don't expect you ever to believe that i
am a man and if you don't want to that's
your choice
i find my other space in the world
that's why i walk the world free
yeah it's a really great point that
you've expressed there and
it's so important because it just feels
that we're being driven apart
and to me i feel sad because it feels
like trans people have become a porn in
this giant game
that's right that's why i say it all the
time we're now being used we're being
used in that system to change something
is it money related well you know i do a
little of my research and when i start
seeing stock market
money watch tell us to invest in trans
surgeries i'm like hey
there it is follow the money my friends
i start seeing
weird stuff and then i'm like wait a
minute am i am i being paranoid
am i you know so i started even thinking
to myself like are they just trying to
help all these trans people
or is pharmaceutical jumping in on it as
surgeons jumping on it
why has it grown in the last year or two
so fast i can't even believe it they're
handing out hormones like
candy you don't even need to go to
mental health care anymore you can just
walk into a clinic say i'm trans
within an hour you're taking
testosterone no
not cool not cool and this is holy [ __ ]
yeah this is a question and and the
reason i'm answering i'm asking this
question
buck is because i i feel that you know
that there's a connection between us
yeah what is it like to take
testosterone and what effect does it
have on your body because
people just say i take hormones and they
just like you know like you take a
vitamin pill
that's what i say earlier i have to
inject testosterone in my body every
week i hate it
i've been doing it for 26 years i still
get like a little i gotta put that
needle in my butt like this
it's a thing it reminds you every week
it reminds me that i'm not a biological
man
every week it reminds me that i am not
the normal person
every week it reminds me that this is
the place of my life
and i just have to deal with it it's
like having you know any other kinds of
things that you're not
normalized so so that being said that's
what i'm trying to say
it's like when we start to put people in
a medicalized space
that's a whole other level there's no
turning back i can't turn back
look at me i can't say i change my mind
i'm i'm actually a woman that would be
insane and so wrong
so why are we not adding a cushion when
i transitioned there was a cushion
we had an actual system i had to go to a
therapist for two years i had to live as
a man for a couple years then i had to
get a note from my therapist to go to
see my endocrinologist
who never ever worked with him you know
i was the first
here in los angeles when this man he had
never worked with a trans
man he only worked with men becoming
women and he said to me
you will be my guinea pig he actually
called me his guinea pig
and i didn't have a choice and that was
the space i was in but i don't want
other people to be in that space and
it's like take your time and think about
it
why are we rushing why are we rushing
kit why are we rushing to get everybody
medical lies and on hormones i don't
that's the part that scares me
what about the counter argument that i
can think to there
we had india willoughby who is a trans
uh gender present tv presenter on our
show
and when i said said to her well if you
could have transitioned at age of five
would you
she was like absolutely right so is that
maybe why people
are rushing they're like well you know
if someone's life is going to be ruined
by having to go through
male puberty etc why don't we get in
there early and
save them and help them out prove it
prove it
prove it to me right now that that child
and now that's one story
that's one story that's not five million
stories prove it that
her one space is gonna change the whole
thing
that's her story that's not my story i
had to remember what i said earlier i
had happy childhood
i don't know if i would have
transitioned because i lived as a boy my
parents that's social transitioning
so i have a counter argument to that and
i do believe that we should
social transition children and i think
what i was saying earlier is i have some
kids here and parents that i work at
they're social transitioning their
children their children are happy
they're playing with the other kids no
one says anything the kid changed his
name to billy or whatever
and everyone calls him billy and they're
all in third grade their graders don't
know [ __ ] right they're just like
playing with each other
and we're we're we are pathologizing
third graders and like two-year-olds
like are you kidding me like come on man
i'm gonna push back on that
a two-year-old might say i'm a boy big
deal
let him just dress like a boy who cares
but why are you so
and why are people celebrating their
trans kids
as if it's this thing i would hate it if
my parents did that
celebrating my what if the child grows
out of it and if by 15 they're no longer
trans then what
do you think that kid's gonna be pissed
that their parents put them on display
when they were two i would be so
would i do you want to promote your
business to an intelligent
audience who don't need to know your
pronouns to buy your product
here at trigonometry we have over 250
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and we frequently get
over three million views a month that's
a lot of new customers
for your business we speak with some of
the biggest guests from the worlds of
politics economics journalism
arts and entertainment all of them have
spent at least
one month in the gulag so you don't have
to and we'll match your product to the
perfect guest for you
american sponsors will be matched with
american guests and so on
that way you know your advert has the
best possible chance
of getting to the right people or as we
call them the wrong people
advertise with us and we'll get your
business cancelled or your money back
contact us by email at marketing at
triggerpod.com
and we'll make your nightmares come true
i want to move on because you know as i
said
about your absolutely correct criticism
uh that we we focus on what strikes me
whenever we've spoken to
to people particularly like you who
transition quite late in life
is you have a unique experience which is
you've lived
both as a man and a woman that's right
talk to me about what you notice
about the process of being uh
treated as a man and being treated as a
woman uh what is
the difference uh you know sometimes a
lot often women will talk to us guys and
say well you know it's
being a woman's like this and you guys
have no idea what it's like
and everyone's like well is it true is
it not true you actually sort of know
the answer i imagine right
that's what i always say who knows women
better than a man who used to be a woman
right so there's a lot my friend first
off let me just tell you
i i love being a man it's just a whole
other space
it's [ __ ] great isn't it i love it
are you kidding me i love it i have so
many dude friends like you guys just
regular dudes who just i hang out with
and i think on some level that made me
enjoy the world because i was accepted
in the world if that makes sense right
so so so that being said the question
was again the question was uh like
living as a woman
and living as a man yeah what have what
have you noticed about
your life about i i don't know about
applying for jobs but like the normal
day-to-day stuff that people talk about
women often talk about
you know there's a different vibe in a
in a women's space as a man space
well there is right there is there's a
hundred percent
is what i told you earlier i was i was
socialized as a woman
and even though i was a butch woman i
was still a woman and you get treated
different oh gosh so here's an example i
used to own a
1955 ford truck that i you know when i
was a chick i was a totally butch chick
and i work on my truck and i was trying
to hyper masculinize you know i wanted
to be a dude so i was as dude as you
could be and
that's pretty duty working on your truck
and i would go to the auto parts store
and they would ne literally dudes would
walk in front of me they would push me
out of the way they would never help me
i would stand in that line for hours
until finally somebody would be like hey
what do you need so
there is a and now if i walk into the
auto parts store it's like i could be
the first dude in line they're like hey
dude what do you need
it's uh night and day the way i walk the
world is night and day you get treated
differently as a woman and that's what i
keep
saying the world is misogynist there is
people don't like women on some level
and people look at women in a down way
as if they're lesser than and there's so
many levels of it i
it could be a whole other show of me and
i could show you the difference of that
and that
but but that being said there is a
difference there's 100 percent of
different how you walk the world how the
way people see you the way you're
treated
i mean it's just night and day for me
and and so
by seeing and living as a woman i have a
lot of compassion for women
and have a lot of compassion for where
they're at and i always say that women's
rights are still way the [ __ ] back there
they're nowhere so now we're putting the
trans
thing into it and it's making it even
more cracked i'm like no
trans women are not women trans women or
women are
trans women or trans women see even
you're confused though
i know i'm like what are they because
it's been inundated it's been put in my
brain right trans women are women
see what they do they do that that's
like very like weird culty [ __ ]
when you start putting stuff in and the
people just see it they immediately just
start saying it
but i i disagree with that trans women
are not women trans women are trans
women
trans men or trans men and if we take
that equation out of there we're
actually doing ourselves a disservice
i don't go to the same doctor you go to
i don't get to have a prostate exam i
have to go to the gynecologist
and that's all other space so you know
what i mean we don't have the same needs
i'm not the same man as you so why do we
take out that trans label i don't
understand that
and buck here's here's the question so
when you transition what was your
favorite thing
about being a man that as a woman
you just didn't have access to or was a
complete struggle for you
so no when i started becoming a man like
i just felt this relief
and you know it was like people saw me i
i can tell you the number one thing for
me was people seeing me as a man because
if you've seen my pictures before you
know i was butch but i still was a
female characteristic and even though i
would tell people i'm a he
they would always call me she so i
understand the misgender thing it's
hurtful
but at the same time as i started
transitioning and started oh my it was
magic it was magic and then when i got
my top surgery and i didn't have any
more breasts and i could
the number one thing for me was to go
around without my shirt on
and to go into the gym and to take my
clothes off with the other guys
and to look like other men and that
really i'm telling you my physical
part of my transition was so important
as you can see i think
it was so important to me it was
important to me to physically look
and feel masculine and so today we get
pushed back on that in the trans
community
it's called passing and now they look
down upon it
as if you're not supposed to do this
you're supposed to just identify as
trans and not
i don't know it's all over the place and
do you think that's part of the problem
this term community when people say you
know the gay community
well look you know there's tens of
thousands of gay people in the uk
they're you know they they're different
they have different political opinions
views of the world
just because you have a sexuality or
you're trans
doesn't really mean necessarily that you
have anything in common with another
trans or gay person
oh my god thank you for saying that my
friend that's just like
oh my god a mature conversation
i don't understand that either i don't
have a lot of trans friends
like i said earlier i have friends from
every walk of life
all kinds of people i don't hang out in
the trans community i think that's
dangerous
any community if you're just you know
stuck in one space all you're hearing is
that
right so you're living in that bubble
and that's that's why there's angry
that's why there's a lot of angry trans
people
because they're living in that one space
and i
keep encouraging them to get out into
the world what's the whole point of
transitioning if you're living in that
same space
aren't you supposed to be transitioning
to go live your life trans is that part
of
this it's not even that i don't even
think about it anymore on some level
it's like i'm part of the world now i do
so many different things
that was my goal to transition to be a
part of the world
i don't feel like they're transitioning
to be a part of the world i feel like
they're transitioning to be trans
which then keeps you locked into this
space and you're not participating in
life
it's a really interesting point and it
resonates with me quite a lot oddly
enough because when i came to britain
from russia
as a kid i i was having a hard time i
didn't really speak the language
and i naturally clung to other russian
people at my school
and my parents were always saying to me
we didn't send you to
england to talk to other russians you
need to
learn the language learn the culture you
need to understand you need to integrate
and
i have russian friends but not a lot of
them and i've certainly never
clung to that community and i guess what
really strikes me about our conversation
with you buck is
you are comfortable in your own skin and
that's where
your ability to be okay with reality
comes in
whereas i think if you had been
uncomfortable with who you are
that's when people start to have to try
and change the world around them
to fit their agenda do you think that's
true no that's an
excellent excellent point my friend and
yeah looking at it i can see that
because
before my transition i was an angry
person i did
act out i did all kinds of crazy stuff
man if i oh it was just insane i can't
even believe my life was homeless i was
a prostitute i was a crackhead i was
i could go on and on i hated myself i
wanted to die it was like
so insane but that being said i i worked
through it and got it and that was such
a long time ago people don't have to go
through that but what there's a lot of
anger in the community
a lot and i don't know what these people
are angry about because the
opportunities to transition
are literally at your fingertips i
didn't have that
i had to hide to seek and seek and seek
and seek
and so again not to say my story is more
tragic than anybody else's
but all i'm trying to say is i don't
know what the anger is about
and i'm wondering if they're being told
to be angry you know what i mean
push back but that doesn't create change
look at you guys you don't even want to
change you don't even want to have a
conversation with that you're
you're disgusted with it which i don't
blame you on some level but that being
said
that's not creating change that's
creating pushback
you see what i mean and so i keep
telling my community why are we pushing
an agenda on people that
clearly don't necessarily believe in it
how can we
figure out a way to meet them in the
middle and say hey wait a minute we have
respect your opinion and i respect my
opinion and let's move forward
that's how you create change by
respecting other people's opinions or
thoughts
and saying how do we work together to
make it a better world but we're not
doing that
and it's it's a really really really
good point buck and it's
a really lovely place also to end the
interview
it's been absolutely brilliant but thank
you so much for coming on the show
uh the last question we always end our
show with is what's the one thing we're
not talking about
as a society but we really should be oh
compassion compassion empathy love those
are my favorite words
we're not talking about how to be
compassionate instead of hateful
and that comes from an echoes out to
everyone in the world
how are you participating in the world
are you putting out hate are you putting
out compassion
because hate will not change anything
compassion will
it's interesting that you say that buck
would just explore a touch uh we've got
a couple more minutes is
okay i'm all down for being
compassionate and i think you know the
way we've had this conversation i think
you get that from me right
yes yes but what strikes me as odd is
the very people who
claim that they are compassionate
nowadays
the ones that are doing a lot of the
hating that's right
that was my message to them right there
you're exact 100
i keep saying it my community is angry
but what are they
angry about they're not saying what
they're angry about they're just calling
people names
they call me transphobic turf all of
those things anyone can you imagine i'm
called transphobic i
hate him oh you have internalized you
have internalized transphobia i'm
thinking wow they're like
totally going deep with this stuff so so
that's not creating change that's
creating hate
so you see what i mean and i understand
why you can't have compassion
when you're getting hate thrown at you
you turn around and have hate back
that's a real thing
it's what you put out in the world you
should get back and it's why i try to
put out more compassion and love and try
to listen
nobody's listening everybody's so angry
and so that's
i think the crux of what the
conversation is here for me
is that we need to get away from the
anger and we need to start having some
dialogue because if we don't both sides
are going to just not work together and
what's going to happen
can be a very disastrous thing for me as
well this this
this actually affects my transition this
whole thing
and you know there's a little box
there's a lot of little bucks out there
and those little bucks don't need to be
caught into this [ __ ] political
conversation they need just to be
getting taken care of so they can move
on in the world and become a better
person
that's a really great point listen thank
you so much for coming on if people want
to
uh follow you and find out more about
what you talk about
uh where where do they go to to
you can find me everywhere just go to
twitter book oh watch out for twitter
kids
a twitter instagram book angel facebook
uh official book
youtube as well oh youtube too i always
forget my official book angel
and i have some good stuff i think
coming up on youtube so check it out
fantastic buck thank you so much for
coming on and thank you all for watching
and listening
we will see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one or raw
show
all of them go out at 7 p.m uk time take
care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below